we're back i'm sitting here with mr
ricky gervais you have a very funny blog
i love doing the blog you love doing the
blog you're so committed to comedy you
you
you give a lot on this blog and one of
the things that you put up on the blog
is you like these
you like these very specific kinds of
self portraits yeah well
last time i showed you that um i like um
taking pictures of myself looking
surprised
looking surprised yes i also put
pictures of myself on there
you've got to try and look as bad as you
can without the use of wigs or makeup
it's just using the own
your own muscles in your face to look
ridiculous
it's a hobby it's a hobby you take these
photos we
we have it this is you looking surprised
very nice very nice i think we have
another one
here there's another one um i think is
there one more
there you are but you look like you're
in a wind tunnel there
looks like you're high in a wind tunnel
um
last time you were here you wanted you
thought
i want to include you want to put your
appearance yes
you had me get on all fours uh i was on
all fours you took this picture and then
uh i believe put it on your blog let's
take a look at that there i am
looking surprised and horrible look at
that
yeah really does look like something you
see in prison
well i wouldn't see it but uh you
no you wouldn't see it no no uh behave
now
you've moved on you've moved on to a new
kind of photograph that you like
which i don't quite understand is this
right you like to
well explain what's happening in this
photo because this is a photo that's on
your blog and i don't
well i don't know what's happening
that's a friend he's a comedian
eminent novelist in in britain called
david when i was around his house and
his children
were playing their new nintendo wii and
i thought i'll show them
how we used to amuse ourselves before
technology and uh
that's and it's there's a recession on
you don't need to spend hundreds of
pounds
on video games that is hours of fun is
that
what is that called by the way i call it
airplanes you call it airplane yeah
is that something that's easy to do do
you need to be an acrobat or an athlete
to do that
uh it will it would make it easier if
you had any sort of dexterity or
much but no i i could i could um well i
could do it with you probably
here oh my gosh is this out of the way
oh i need someone
i need somebody to take a picture okay
we need something we need to get this
i want to get the do you get this on the
blog you know it is on television we
could probably take a frame no
you have nine hd cameras right here oh
it's got to be this way
there's a producer on this show as well
you never know just press that one
right everybody okay yeah
okay what do i do
which side do you dress sir what okay i
need to i need to put my heels but we're
either side of your testicles
and they're both on one side
they will be after this right okay
right uh so now let me um let's lean
forward no no wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
wait what do i do wrong okay okay that's
okay that's good my legs aren't long
enough you can still be standing on the
floor
right okay okay wait wait wait
[Applause]
hanzo
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's going to be great that's going
to be sweet that's going to be on ricky
gervais's blog
[Applause]
there's really nothing we can discuss
after that
this is like you're visiting me in my
sort of cubicle at the office
okay so so you want a permission to do
for you i really would i really like a
promotion uh ricky gervais out of
england the stand-up special
a lot of people are going to tune in for
this it airs november 15th
at 00 pm on hbo ricky we're huge fans
you